[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue laurence
cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes
avaient la parole leur collègue monsieur
de minutes
monsieur le président madame la ministre
après deux semaines de grèves de
manifestations notamment celle d'hier à
l'appel de toutes les organisations
syndicales après les scandales qui ont
éclaboussé votre ancien et éphémère
secrétaire d'état vous continuez à
défendre l'indéfendable en répétant que
tout le monde sera gagnant avec votre
projet de réforme des retraites
dans tous les pays où le système de
retraite à points était mis en oeuvre
l'ensemble du monde du travail a dû en
réalité travailler plus longtemps pour
gagner moins
vous essayez de monter les françaises et
les français les uns contre les autres
régimes spéciaux contre régime général
jeunes contre vieux mais tout le monde a
bien compris que votre pseudo régime
universel était une machine à fabriquer
précarité misère sociale
les manifestantes et manifestants d'hier
sont autant de porte-voix pour démonter
votre entreprise d'intox d'enfumage tout
le monde comme les associations
féministes les syndicalistes réunis
lundi soir à la maison des métallos pour
s'élever contre votre argumentaire
affirmant que les femmes allaient être
les grandes gagnantes
quand elles sont les premières perdantes
madame la ministre
la france est dans la rue personne ne
veut de votre nez face projet à part vos
amis du medef et de la haute finance
ma question est donc simple quand allez
vous retirer votre réforme pour vous
répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités la santé monsieur al raya
taquet monsieur ministre merci monsieur
le président m
mesdames et sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs dans la lignée de vos propos
permettez moi tout d'abord d'excuser
l'absence d'agnès busin et de laurent
qui travestit nouveau secrétaire d'état
en charge des retraites dont je me
permets de saluer
de saluer la nomination merci comment
permettez moi madame la sénatrice tout
d'abord de de commencer en disant que le
gouvernement a bien conscience des
conséquences pénibles que la grève peut
avoir sur le territoire nous savons que
beaucoup de nos compatriotes se lèvent
tôt le matin pour aller travailler
doivent faire face en île de france mais
aussi comme ailleurs sur notre
territoire à des transports saturé soyez
convaincus que le gouvernement s'attelle
à ce que dans le quotidien des français
mais plus largement alors que
s'approchent les fêtes de fin d'année
chacun puisse aller retrouver ses
proches le premier ministre la ministre
des solidarités de la santé et le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
retraites rencontre en ce moment même
les partenaires sociaux et demain une
multilatérales avec l'ensemble des
syndicats des organisations syndicales
se tiendra à matignon nous avons engagé
madame la sénatrice une réforme du
système français de retraite pour le
rendre universel
et cela implique sans dresser aucun
français contre aucun français
effectivement la disparition des régimes
spéciaux nous réformons madame la
sénatrice parce que chaque régime a ses
propres règles et que les français n'ont
pas tous les mêmes droits lorsqu'ils
partent à la retraite
vous évoquez la situation des femmes
vous le savez une femme salariés du
privé aujourd'hui a droit à huit
trimestres par enfant alors qu'une femme
dans la fonction publique n'a le droit
qu'à 2 trimestre nous réformons aussi
parce que nous voulons donner redonner
de la confiance dans notre système de
retraite et redonner de la confiance
c'est dans ces redonner de la confiance
dans le principe de solidarité
intergénérationnelle
le système n'est plus adapté aux
changements de métier pénalise les
personnes qui passent d'un statut à un
autre c'est un système fondé sur les
statuts et non pas sur les trajectoires
individuelles de chacun de nos
compatriotes
par exemple le minimum contributif à
1000 euros pour les françaises et
français qui n'ont jamais eu le droit
je pense notamment aux agriculteurs je
ne pense pas que vous soyez
opposé à ce genre de réforme
l'inauguration
l'instauration de ce régime universel
constituera un progrès ira vers plus de
justice sociale je vous le dis madame la
sénatrice cette réforme des retraites
est l'une des réformes qui sera porteuse
de plus de progrès social
au cours de ce quinquennat
madame cohen
la nomination du nouveau monsieur
retraites car à son actif le
licenciement d'une caissière d'auchan
pour quelques centimes d'euros est loin
d'apaiser l'inquiétude et la colère dans
le pays
contrairement ce que vous dites les
mobilisations sont largement soutenus
par les françaises et les français qui
ne veulent ni sacrifier leurs vieux
jours
ni ceux de leurs enfants quant à vos
arguments comptable ils sont nuls et non
avenus
le pognon de dingue il y en a c'est
l'explosion des revenus du capital qui
ne participent pas au financement des
retraites
qu'attendez vous pour le taxer
qu'attendez vous pour arrêter les
exonérations de cotisations patronales à
hauteur de 66 milliards d'euros
qu'attendez vous pour faire appliquer la
loi l'égalité salariale 11 millions
d'euros pour la cnav
qu'attendez vous pour faire sauter le
verrou des 14% du pile pour la part des
dépenses consacrées aux retraites
vous êtes responsable de la situation du
pays il faut retirer ce projet c'est
tout ce qu'il ya à faire
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre la question est simple
précise comment un haut-commissaire aux
fonctionnaires peut-il cumulé une
rémunération supplémentaire avec le
droit de la fonction publique qu'elle
réglerait pas elle était appliquée
deuxième question comment un
haut-commissaire élevé au rang de membre
du gouvernement peut continuer à violer
la constitution en étant qualifié
d'erreur pour vous répondre la parole de
ministre au chargeur le soin avec le
parlement je fais no merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur sénateur belge pas
cher je vais essayer de répondre très
simplement sur le process en vous
rappelant quand même que jean paul
delevoye
compte tenu des erreurs qu'il avait
commises et qu'il avait requis l'a
reconnu lui-même avait déjà décidé en
début de semaine de démissionner de ses
fonctions l'approché dire la procédure
la procédure elle est très simple je
vais essayer de répondre à monsieur ben
asher la procédure elle est très simple
quand vous êtes nommé ministre
le service de secrétariat général du
gouvernement vous donne un certain
nombre de documents que vous contresigné
d'ailleurs et qui vous rappelle les
obligations qui sont les vôtres et c'est
à vous ensuite de remplir ce document
est de vous conformer aux obligations en
particulier c'est ça dont vous faites
partie de vous parler en particulier
l'article 23 de la constitution qui
indiquent précisément est clairement on
ne peut pas cumuler une activité une
rémunération de ministre avec une autre
activité privée ensuite il appartient à
celui qui rentre au gouvernement de s'y
conformer de transmettre sa déclaration
à la haute autorité
ce qui a été fait la haute autorité a
publié conformément à la loi le texte
est aussitôt connus rendu public
ça c'est un dialogue entre la haute
autorité le membre du gouvernement
aussitôt connue cette déclaration le
secrétariat du gouvernement conformément
aux réglementations et à la loi a
indiqué l'inconstitutionnalité manifeste
contenu de la déclaration qui étaient
fournies par monsieur delevoye est donc
pour dire les choses très simplement
jean paul delevoye a reconnu ses erreurs
chacun est dans son rôle
le secrétariat découverte du
gouvernement il est là pour informer les
ministres
j'en sais quelque chose comme les
collègues qui sont autour de moi pour
informer des obligations après nous
sommes dans un processus déclaratif et
il appartient à la haute autorité de
faire en sorte de vérifier la conformité
des déclarations avec la réalité de
regarder s'il ya des sujets
d'inconstitutionnalité
monsieur le sénateur j'ai été député
j'ai comme vous sans doute été
confrontés à la nécessité par la loi et
c'est une bonne chose de faire une
déclaration à la haute autorité
on m'a donné des documents auxquels il
fallait me conformer
chacun est dans son rôle et
manifestement ya des erreurs qui ont été
commises par monsieur delevoye alors ne
cherchons pas il me serait pas venu à
l'esprit de remettre en cause des
services de l'assemblée nationale si
j'avais connu commis une erreur ça n'est
donc pas le cas ne remettons pas en
cause les services qui font bien leur
travail c'est manifestement une erreur
et je le répète que jean paul delevoye a
reconnu je vous remercie madame la
ministre
en ce 14e jour de grève contre la
réforme des retraites
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
commencent à publier leurs premières
statistiques qui mesure l'impact
économique de ce mouvement social sur
les commerces et les entreprises comme
nous pouvions anticiper c'est
région parisienne où la grève dans les
transports pose le plus de problèmes et
impacte le plus grand nombre de nos
compatriotes que les conséquences
économiques sont les plus lourdes les
pertes d'activités déclaré par les
professionnels sont conséquentes et
elles auront dans les semaines et les
mois à venir des conséquences sociales
avec inévitablement son lot de
sensations d'activité de placements en
chômage partiel voire définitif alors
que le mois de décembre et la fin de
l'année représentent souvent une part
conséquente du volume d'affaires de
beaucoup de commerces parisiens
les chiffres de cette première moitié du
mois sont inquiétants moins 80% pour les
commerces situés dans les gares ou à
proximité 50% dans les magasins
parisiens 30% dans les hôtels avec une
cascade d'annulations 35% chez les
traiteurs 40% pour les cafés 50% pour
les restaurants en moyenne près de deux
tiers des artisans ou commerçants
franciliens se déclare impactés alors
madame la ministre que prévoyez vous
pour aider les entreprises qui vont se
retrouver en difficulté au delà bien sûr
du maintenant traditionnel et allemand
des impôts et cotisations sociales
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
agnès pannier relâché ce que d'arrêter
reproduisent l'économie des finances
d'abb la ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice du bain comme vous
le savez depuis le 5 décembre le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
et moi même faisons le point tous les
jours tous les deux jours avec les
fédérations avec les chambres
consulaires pour prendre la mesure de
l'impact des blocages que nous subissons
en ce moment essentiellement comme vous
l'avez dit en ile-de-france sur le
commerce et l'artisanat
il en résulte une situation contrastée
vous avez donné quelques chiffres ces
chiffres ne représentent pas totalement
la réalité commerciale en particulier
vous avez des commerçants qui s'en
sortent très bien d'autres qui sont en
grande difficulté
c'est pour cela que lorsque nous avons
réuni mercredi dernier
l'ensemble des fédérations physiquement
nous avons pris des décisions fortes ces
décisions ne se limite pas à
repousser les échéances fiscales et
sociales dont je rappelle qu'elles ont
permis d'apporter 300 millions d'euros
de trésorerie de cotisations sociales et
100 millions d'euros de trésorerie de
cotiser d'imposition lors du mouvement
du gilet jaune ce n'est pas l'épaisseur
du trait et c'est d'ailleurs ce
dispositif que les fédérations nous ont
demandés nous final nous finançons
également du chômage partiel nous
facilitons le travail le dimanche et
nous avons un dispositif
d'accompagnement des entreprises les
plus touchées au travers des ccsf qui va
leur permettre de gérer leur trésorerie
au delà de ça je souhaite que ce
dispositif soit au plus proche des
commerçants et des artisans et dès
demain nous aurons des brigades mobiles
qui useront à la rencontre sur le
terrain des commerçants pour leur
expliquer le dispositif nous avons un
numéro unique dans les directs dans les
cci dans les c est ma et puisque vous
aborder la situation de paris j'aimerais
également voir des prises de position
plus forte de la part de la mairie à qui
nous avons donné six cent mille euros
pour la relance commerciale et qui à ce
stade n'a pas affiché de volonté ni de
revoir le sujet des parkings ni des
circulations ni des terrasses
je vous remercie madame du mort merci
madame la ministre je ne suis pas
certaine que cette réponse suffise à
rassurer ceux qui aujourd'hui porte le
commerce à bout de bras pour ma part
j'en ai rencontré peu dont les activités
fonctionnent bien et en ce qui concerne
la mairie de paris là je suis pas
habilité à parler en son nom
en tout cas ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que il faudrait que le
gouvernement entende ce message dallaire
car l'inquiétude madame la ministre est
immense vraiment et le risque économique
est avérée monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre juste
un petit incident tu sais pas au sénat
qui veut venir qu'il faut venir plaider
la cause des agriculteurs nous avions
voté ici à l'unanimité une augmentation
de leur retraite à 85% du smic
il y a deux ans de soi
mais nous avons nous avons un point
d'accord nous avons le meilleur système
de retraite au monde
il est encore perfectible et son
financement est assuré sur le long terme
déjà si vous cessiez d'y puiser vous
avez résolu de casser le système plutôt
que de l'améliorer avec pour conséquence
inquiétudes injustice et pauvreté sans
garanties réelles sur la valeur du point
sans précision sur les 12 millions sur
les 12 milliards pour les enseignants
sans correctif pour les carrières
erratique des jeunes des neuf cent mille
chômeurs que vous allez fabriquer les
carrières interrompues et cetera des
pensions de réversion à 62 ans au lieu
de 55 et j'en oublie
l'âge pivot lui sera lourd de
conséquences quand la moyenne de vie en
bonne santé est inférieur et deux ans de
galère de plus pour les 70% d'inactifs
vous avez déclenché de la colère vous
avez fait de la provocation
vous avez choisi décembre non sans
arrière pensée aussi vous porterez la
pleine responsabilité des désagréments
qu'ils éprouveront nos concitoyens vous
exhorter à une trêve
sans la souhaitait vraiment car quels
gestes faites vous il suffirait
d'abandonner dès aujourd'hui la
référence inopportune et punitive à
l'âge pivot de remettre sur le métier
votre ouvrage le reprendre totalement
sans dogme sur le système par les vrais
associer les corps intermédiaires
écouter la population pour présenter un
projet de justice et d'avenir
un projet digne de confiance une
confiance que vous avez 0d et que bien
peu vous accorde encore
êtes vous prêts à cela pour vous
répondre
la parole est à la secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des solidarités
l'âme du boss avait la parole le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs vous parlez de solidarité
depuis le début c'est bien le ministère
des solidarités qui porte cette réforme
de justice
le projet de réforme est solide et
cohérent il a été nourri par un travail
intense de concertation avec l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales patronales
mais aussi les citoyens
cette concertation se poursuit
d'ailleurs encore cette semaine
et en ce moment même ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est la construction et le
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
puis sa présentation au parlement parce
qu'il y aura aussi un travail avec les
parlementaires que vous êtes le
gouvernement ne fait pas d'économies
dans la réforme des retraites il n'y a
aucune mesure budgétaire ni en 2020 ni
en 2021 les mesures de redistribution
entreront en vigueur dès 2022 et
peut-être permettez-moi de revenir sur
un exemple sur des personnes que nous
entendons peut parler
donc moi je m'occupe en particulier dans
le cadre de la stratégie de prévention
de lutte contre la pauvreté je pense
assez près de deux millions de
bénéficiaires du rsa dont la moitié sont
des dispositifs depuis plus de quatre
ans ce sont des personnes qui ont arrêté
de réfléchir de penser qu'un jour ils
auraient un droit à une retraite c'est
justement avec ce notre réforme que nous
allons pouvoir
en effet leur faire accéder à une
retraite parce que chaque point chaque
heure travaillée contreras et quand vous
êtes en insertion professionnelle que
vous reprenez un travail que vous êtes
dans l'insertion par l'activité
économique êtes sur un temps partiel
chaque temps travaillent et cotisent
rassure un accès droits à la retraite au
plus tard donc ce sont ces personnes
avec qui nous travaillons nous
travaillons aussi pour une réforme quand
on dit de justice et de social et je
pense que monsieur nationale heures vous
en conviendrez
quand une maman seule qui a eu deux
enfants qui a élevé ses enfants qui a eu
une carrière hachée qui s'est arrêté
pour ses congés maternité qui en a
actuellement quand elle va arriver à 60
ans se pose la question et qu'il faudra
qu'à se rendre compte qu'il faut
qu'elles travaillent jusqu'à 67 ans
parce que c'est votre système que vous
avez mis en place avec le système de
décote jusqu'à 67 ans ce sont ces publié
qu'un que nous prenons en compte dans la
réforme jour merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
elisabeth bornes ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
madame un ministre je sais qu'elle est
pas là mais madame la ministre hier le
mouvement de grève a franchi un cap
en effet la cgt de la rte a revendiqué
les coupures d'électricité à travers
toute la france et a menacé de retirer
10 récidiver pardon durant les fêtes
c'est inacceptable et nous le condamnons
vivement ce sont près de cent soixante
dix mille foyers des quartiers entiers
qui ont été impartis dans toute la
france quarante mille à lyon 40000
orléans à nantes et près de 50000 dans
mon département de la gironde
au delà des particuliers ce sont aussi
des services publics indispensables qui
ont parfois été bloqués des crèches des
hôpitaux des services administratifs je
pense aussi aux commerçants qui
subissent là une double peine après
avoir subi les rêves des gilet jaune
madame la ministre outre la gêne
occasionnée
ces coupures sont manifestement illégal
la direction de rta a annoncé que des
plaintes avaient été déposées et que des
sanctions disciplinaires seraient mises
en oeuvre
pour autant ce syndicat semble indiquer
qu'il n'hésiterait pas à reconduire ce
type d'action en agitant la menace de
coupure plus importante
madame un ministre mais question sont
donc très simple
quelle action au gouvernement quand il
prendre afin que ces actes soient pas
simplement condamné mais également
empêché quel discours de responsabilité
adressez vous aux soi disant défenseurs
de ce service public
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame emmanuelle wargon
secrétaire d'état auprès de l'ami de la
transition écologique l'homme la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateur alain cazabonne
plusieurs coupures d'électricité ont
effectivement été signalé du fait des
agissements volontaire de la part de
personnes cagoulées qui se sont
introduites dans des postes électriques
ces coupures ont eu lieu essentiellement
à nantes à nice à bordeaux et en gironde
comme vous l'avez dit à lyon et à
orléans plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui ont subi ces coupures
et de nombreux établissements cinq
cliniques une caserne de pompiers à lyon
mais aussi des dégâts dans des
entreprises locales je pense à béziers
par exemple avec même une intoxication
d'employés liés à la coupure électrique
d'un four industriel et à perpignan une
mise hors de service du réseau des feux
tricolores ce qui évidemment met en
danger la population
si la plupart des installations et des
habitations ne sont coupées que quelques
secondes grâce à la redondance de notre
réseau plusieurs milliers de personnes
ont quand même subi des coupures pour
une période plus longue de plus
minutes à plusieurs heures les
conséquences de ces actes pourraient
être dramatiques
et ce n'est pas admissible je condamne
donc avec la plus grande fermeté les
coupures d'électricité volontaires
survenus ces dernières heures sur le
réseau électrique
si je respecte comme bien sûr tout le
gouvernement le droit de grève
constitutionnellement garantis ce droit
de grève ne peut pas être une excuse à
de telles actions
ces actes sont heureusement le fait
d'une petite minorité qui ne sont pas
toujours des salariés des opérateurs
eux-mêmes et que je ne confonds pas avec
l'immense majorité des agents du service
public qui sont attachés à leur mission
ces agissements ne peuvent pas rester
sans suite et appelle la plus grande
sévérité
la ministre elisabeth borne à d'ailleurs
demandé à aînés 10 et à rte que chaque
acte face ainsi l'objet systématiquement
d'une plainte et des procédures
disciplinaires nécessaires
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous sommes au bord du
drame
l'hôpital public se meurt c'est ainsi
que débute la tribune publiée il ya
quelques jours par 660 médecins
hospitaliers qui s'adressant
gouvernement affirme envisagé de
démissionner s'ils ne sont pas écoutés a
marseille le service de réanimation
pédiatrique fait face à une épidémie
avec 20% de ces lits fermés 12
infirmière ils sont manquantes des
années signe à sion sont adressés aux
internes pour tenter de maintenir tant
bien que mal la permanence des soins au
chu de toulouse 243 signalement révélant
de graves dysfonctionnements ont été
recensés en une année l'établissement
est au bord de l'implosion à l'ap-hp il
y avait 400 postes d'infirmières
vacances en septembre il y en a 6 192
cette semaine dans de nombreux
territoires la situation se répète
elle inquiète nos concitoyens elle nous
inquiète surtout c'est bon madame la
ministre
la situation continue de s'aggraver
malgré vos annonces successives
quand comptez-vous apporter des réponses
à la hauteur de la grave crise celle
d'un affaissement que ville hôpital
public dans nos territoires
bon ma parole et secrétaire d'état
de la sorte et madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur juillet votre constat la
ministre la partager dès ses premiers
instants au niveau du quand elle est
arrivée au niveau du ministère puisque
elle a travaillé de nombreuses années
dans les hôpitaux et à la vécu au
quotidien en effet cette dégradation qui
a trop été longtemps et trop longue pour
les hôpitaux et c'est pour ça qu'elle a
mis en place l'ensemble de son de ses
différents plans de ma santé 2022
justement pour pouvoir articuler le soin
de ville et le soin hospitalier pour
pouvoir aussi travaillé sur laval la
sortie en hôpital et les lits dont ils
peuvent avoir besoin derrière mais le
constat qui a été fait aussi et
d'entendre les inquiétudes des
professionnels et des soignants et
également des élus mais aussi des
patients l'effort de soutien à l'hôpital
et notamment l'hôpital public est réel
et massif
nous donnons au personnel de l'hôpital
aux soignants aux médecins aux
paramédicaux des moyens et des primes
qu'ils reconnaissent leurs engagements
et qui prennent en permanence le soin et
qui prennent le travail au quotidien et
nous reconnaissons ce travail-là par
cette reconnaissance avec cette
revalorisation
nous donnons à chaque hôpital de
nouvelles marges de manoeuvre
financières ce sont 1,5 milliard d'euros
de budget supplémentaires sur trois ans
pour recruter moderniser ouvrir des lits
là où il en faut là où il y en a besoin
grâce à cet argent les hôpitaux vont
reconstituer leurs capacités à investir
et nous allons les soulager également
financièrement d'un tiers de leur dette
soit 10 milliards d'euros
enfin nous sommes engagés à ce que les
tarifs des hôpitaux
c'est à dire les prix que facturent les
hôpitaux à l'assurance maladie
leurs tarifs augmenteront pendant trois
ans après quasiment une baisse c'est
d'être dernières décennies nous
répondons également à l'attractivité sur
les métiers avec plusieurs primes parce
que la wii des postes qui sont ouverts
il faut aussi pouvoir attirer les
professionnels sur ces métiers là et
donc c'est ce que nous faisons avec
plusieurs primes et aussi la
simplification et les assouplissements
je vous donne un exemple concret un
infirmier dans un service d'urgence et
pratiquants de nouveaux actes gagnera
plus de 150 euros nets par mois dans le
cadre d'un protocole de coopération
je vous remercie monsieur daumier
madame la ministre toutes les mesures
que vous avez présenté toutes les
annonces ne produisent pas les effets
vous ex compter accepté ce constat vous
voyez que les professionnels de santé
continuent à fuir
l'hôpital public moi je vous appelle
madame la ministre a entamé une large
concertation
on appelle sera l' on appellera ça des
états généraux ou un grenelle de la
santé mais il faut collectivement
rediscuter les missions de l'hôpital
public ce que notre société nos pays
attend de son hôpital et pas toujours
lui confier une nouvelle mission sans
lui en donner les moyens
les organisations et les financements
sont à revoir
et malheureusement malheureusement on
n'avait vu quand le chef de l'état lancé
grand débat national qui l'avait oublié
la santé les français lui ont répondu en
la mettant au premier rang des
préoccupations
il faut entamer enfin ce grand projet
débattre ensemble de la place de
l'hôpital public et des moyens qu'on lui
consacre
merci mon cher que l'ale merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
quelle déception quatre ans après
l'accord historique de paris qui avait
suscité tant d'espoir et d'enthousiasmé
la coop 25 s'achève sont des décisions
insignifiante échec à relever l'ambition
à réglementer les marchés carbone fiasco
annoncé du mécanisme des pertes et
préjudice envers les pays en voie de
développement aujourd'hui inaction des
états est pointée du doigt et creuse le
fossé démocratique entre les dirigeants
et les aspirations citoyennes où se
situe notre crédibilité quand notre
président pourtant sacré champion du
monde est aux abonnés absents
c'est un lourd maintenant à la politique
politiques à la cause climatique quelle
ironie d'ailleurs quand le stand de la
france à madrid
afficher sur un écran de manière décalée
et quasi surréaliste mobilisation
générale comme une radicalité
désincarnée de dernière chance
les générations futures sont dans la rue
et nous interpelle face à une promesse
d'avenir qui s'efface fonte du
pergélisol progression des déserts
canicules à répétition baisse drastique
de la biodiversité les objectifs dérape
sur la possibilité d'intégrer dans notre
société l'arrière
et et du changement climatique pourtant
sur cet échec vous arguez déjà la coop
26 le rôle de la france dans le grand le
green deal européen ou encore la
convention à venir sur la biodiversité
ce sont des mots
regardons vos actes là l'homme n'a pas
offert de véritables mobilité verte ne
permet pas de lutter contre la pollution
de l'air et reporte l'interdiction des
moteurs thermiques à 2040 égal il n'a
pas gravé dans la loi alerte enix
l'interdiction du glyphosate
l'interdiction des emballages plastique
à usage unique n'interviendra qu'en 2040
à nouveau le mot urgence at il pour vous
un sens notre modèle de consommation est
dépassée nous l'avons épuisé nous allons
de reculade en reculade et le temps des
grands messes inopérante devrait être
derrière nous quand assurez-vous le rôle
qui est le vôtre pour vous répondre la
parole des tca la secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire où la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice angèle
tréville oui alors que l'urgence
climatique est là alors que les citoyens
se mobilisent partout dans le monde
l'ambition a manqué à cette coop 25 et
la france le regrette vivement
je voudrais remercier la présidente
chilienne de cette coop et l'espagne
pays d'accueil qui n'ont pas ménagé
leurs efforts pour que cette rencontre
internationale sur le climat puisse
produire des effets et durant deux
semaines la france s'est mobilisée comme
peu de pays l'ont fait avec l'union
européenne avec nos partenaires pour ne
pas accepter le recul des engagements de
l'accord de paris et pour rappeler à
l'action en vue de la coop 26 à glasgow
je rappelle que le premier ministre
s'est rendu avec brune poirson à
l'ouverture de cette coop et
qu'elisabeth borgne s'est également
rendu dans le segment ministériel pour
les négociations sur l'accord de clôture
le résultat est certes décevant j'en
conviens cette coop a néanmoins permis
d'acter certaine avancée utile à la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord de paris je pense
par exemple à la création d'un groupe de
travail sur l'accompagnement des pays
vulnérables dès 2020 à la mobilisation
du réseau de santiago pour faciliter les
collaborations face aux risques naturels
ou à la création d'un nouveau fonds
fiduciaire consacrée à la biodiversité
nous devons continuer à travailler
notamment avec nos partenaires de
l'union européenne pour adopter le plus
rapidement possible un objectif rehaussé
de réduction de nos émissions d'ici à
2030 qui est l'un des enjeux de la
prochaine coop
je rappelle qu'à la coop 25 comme à
toutes les causes d'ailleurs c'est
l'union européenne qui négocie en notre
nom à tous
l'accord qui vient de lettres obtenues
en europe pour que l'union européenne
devienne le premier continent neutre en
carbone à l'horizon 2050 et pour
réhausser nos objectifs et nos ambitions
en 2030 est un accord historique et nous
met sur le bon chemin
[Musique]